ja und dieses Bild hier das wirft bei
mir Fragen auf eine lange Autoschlange
vor der Schule ja Eltern bringen ihre
Kinder zum Unterricht und das sieht auf
dieser bei Frankfurt in der Nähe von
Frankfurt Straße tagtäglich so aus ja
aber nicht nur dort sie liebe Zuschauer
sie kennen solche Staus durch Eltern
Taxis vielleicht auch aus ihrem Ort also
zu meiner Schulzeit war das
unvorstellbar Kinder sind gelaufen auf
weite Strecken oder mit dem Fahrrad
gefahren oder eben auch mal mit dem Bus
wir fragen uns was ist da los haben
Eltern zu viel Angst zu viel Panik
trauen sie den Kindern nichts zu nehmen
ihn lieber jede lass sofort aus der Hand
nehmen sie damit den Kindern aber auch
die Möglichkeit zu wachsen zu reifen und
vor allem auch selbstständig zu werden
das besprechen wir jetzt hier in dieser
Runde viele andere ist nur deine Kinder
auch immer mit dem Eltern Taxi zur
Schule kutschiert dann ist dann vor der
Schule ja
[Gelächter]
ich nicht oder meine Frau oder ich habe
noch ein Sohn der zur Schule geht meine
jüngster und da ist das auch so die
haben auch so ein bus service der da
organisiert ist wo die Kinder dann
gemeinschaftlich dahin fahren die Schule
ist relativ weit weg ist auch auf dem
Land also ein bisschen nicht so gut
erreichbar mit normalen Bussen und
anderen Verkehrsmitteln aber trotzdem
das ist so aufgekommen
stimmt also eigentlich ist es ich bin
auch zu Fuß von der Schule nach Hause
gegangen
aber irgendwann kam das so Schulweg
wurde bedrohlich ja oder man hat es
gedacht eine Autos wurden schneller
Tempo 30 werde auch nicht so verbreitet
und dann hat sich sowas ja sind so eine
Helikopter hat die Tüte da entwickelt
ähm gepaart mit Praktikabilität da will
man den Kindern wahrscheinlich nicht
zumuten da
anderthalb Stunden vorher aufzustehen
deswegen die ehrliche Antwort ja
vielleicht dann auch so ein bisschen
faul geworden also bevor man jetzt in
der Früh ewig ausdiskutiert doch du
kriegst es aus gerade das
passt schon das schaffst du schon sagt
man ja gut okay wir nehmen einfach mit
und fahren
faul nicht sondern ganz im Gegenteil es
ist wer schon einfacher einfacher das
Kind dann aufs Rad zu setzen und zu
sagen hier fahr mal dahin ich soll im
Gegenteil du musst ja dann dahin fahren
du musst manchmal wenn zweites quält
sich ja selber durch den Staub wir sehen
das da kein kein Elternteil hat das Spaß
glaube ich in dieser Schlange zu stehen
die du gezeigt hast ne nein ich glaube
es gibt so eine so eine zusätzliche
Fürsorge und denkt nein das Kind muss
dann bietet vielleicht auch Lust an der
Zeit dann ist ja viel mehr im Stress als
vielleicht war vor 30 40 Jahren ist so
war und und und will vielleicht ein
bisschen Zeit weiter wobei die sehr gut
auf verzichten können im Auto die
Wahrheit sieht dann anders aus aber
vielleicht weil die Kinder in der Regel
selten Lust haben sich dann zu
unterhalten aber das ist vielleicht auch
so ein Punkt bist du noch so wie ich
Generation in den Regenschirm mit und
los geht's laufen wir in die Schule viel
Spaß absolut und ich komme aus
Schleswig-Holstein er liegt jetzt auch
noch besonders viel und trotzdem dann
früh morgens raus und zur Schule
spätestens ab der dritten Klasse glaube
ich und ich muss auch sagen ich halte
das
endlich für ein Teil sozusagen der der
schulischen Ausbildung dass man zu Recht
kommt in seinem Alltag seine Umwelt auch
kennenlernt möglicherweise auch Gefahren
kennenlernt und zu Fuß dahin kommt oder
mit dem Fahrrad ich lasse durchaus
gelten Fragen der Sicherheit wo man sagt
ich habe ein bisschen besorgen was weiß
ich stark gefahrene Straße finde ich
nicht so gut bringe ich die Kinder
vielleicht lieber hin aber hier wenn wir
uns die Aufnahme hier angesehen haben so
eine Privatschule da käme man ja auch
problemlos mit dem Bus hin da fährt also
ein Bus habe ich gelesen bei dieser
Geschichte hin der ist nicht sehr stark
genutzt ganz offensichtlich stattdessen
sieht so aus das ist ja wie samstags
irgendwie im Olympiastadion wo die Masse
da mit dem Auto dahin strömen das kann
ich nicht verstehen bei einer Schule das
ist ein Defizit in Erziehung für meine
ja auch angebrachte Sicherheit äh Aspekt
sehr als Anwalt sie kennen als Jurist
mit Sicherheit auch ein paar Statistiken
ist es nur so ein diffuses Gefühl von
Eltern wir müssen auf unsere Kinder
wirklich besser aufpassen in diesen
Zeiten oder ist er eben auch was dran an
dieser Angst ich fahre lieber überall
hin nicht alleine auf der Straße
unterwegs
ich glaube das ist eher gefühlt eine
Angst als vielleicht tatsächlich
vorhandene Angst ja
gut mein Sohn in dem es eben auch schon
mal was wieder fahren nebenwohnheit die
Schuhe und die Jacke abgenommen und so
weiter es möchte man vielleicht ja gerne
den Kindern ersparen aber deshalb die
Kinder sozusagen nicht mal mit dem
Fahrrad zur Schule fahren zu lassen
genau das eben kennenzulernen früher ich
bin immer selber zur Schule gefahren mit
dem Fahrrad selbstverständlich jeden Tag
auch bei Wind und Wetter das gehört in
der Tat mit zu Erziehung dass man das
kann und dass man auch seine Umwelt da
kennenlernt da bin ich ganz ihre
Auffassung da sieht man ja auch in
dieser diskuss beispielsweise Herr Busen
sieht man in Ausbildungsbetrieben dass
sie zum Teil immer mehr auch sagen wir
haben Lehrlinge die sind gar nicht mehr
selbstständig die packen da gar nicht
mehr mit an glauben Sie dass diese Art
von Erziehung wenn wir das einmal so
über den Bogen schlagen auch
Auswirkungen hat auf die
Selbstständigkeit also das ist ein gutes
Thema also die Selbstständigkeit die
fängt das schon damit an dass die Kinder
selber was machen sollen und wenn ihr
selber zur Schule müssen zu meiner Zeit
unvorstellbar dass jemand mit dem Auto
zur Schule gebracht worden wäre das
heißt so ein bisschen länger her aber
das war unvorstellbar und die Kinder
auch ich bin froh dass meine Enkelkinder
mit dem Fahrrad zur Schule fahren
erstmal werden sie wach morgen sind sie
zur Schule fahren wenn sie wiederkommen
damit sie mal ein bisschen frische Luft
schnappen und die Kinder die aus dem
Auto getragen werden aus der Schule
wieder ins Auto reingetragen werden ins
Haus getragen werden ein bisschen über
die können nicht selbstständig werden
die Kinder müssen auch lernen mit einem
Gerät zu fahren und damit umzugehen und
das ist die Entwicklung die gehört dazu
auch ob ich zu Fuß oder mit dem Fahrrad
gehen ist ganz egal aber glauben sie
machen gehen viele Eltern diesen Weg
nicht mehr ist das Bequemlichkeit ist
das zu große Sorge ist das einfach auch
ein Pragmatismus bei uns ist es in der
Früh trubbelig deswegen alle ab ins Auto
und los
ich finde das ist eine übermütigkeit
also das Foto kenne ich habe jetzt
gesehen ich kenne die Straße nicht es
kann natürlich sein dass es an dieser
Straße überhaupt keinen Fahrradweg gibt
dann wäre so eine landwirtschaftliche
Straße wo zwei Autos kaum nebeneinander
fahren können sehr gefährlich für die
Kinder wenn ich mit dem Fahrrad fahren
das kann natürlich da auch ein Grund
sein es gibt eine solche Ideen natürlich
überall in Deutschland ne viele Eltern
Taxis die vor den Schulen warten Staus
Anwohner die genervt sind ja die Kinder
werden überbütet und das ist ein Fehler
der mussten die schon eventuell mal auf
die Idee kommen vielleicht man
Sportlehrer und Polizisten ein paar
Leute einladen und den Eltern klar
machen das ist viel gesünder ist mit dem
Fahrrad oder zu Fuß zur Schule gehen
viele Eltern machen wahrscheinlich gar
keine
darüber ob das nun besser oder
schlechter ist
da gibt es einfach viel zu tun dass nur
wir tun so als würde die
Selbstständigkeit alleine auf dem
Schulweg da für Kinder nun erarbeitet
das ist ja nicht der Fall für den
Kindern können im Sportverein können
können bei sonstigen Projekten können
mit Freunden können dann am Nachmittag
wenn sie dann Zeit haben raus können
selber einkaufen fahren von zu Hause
oder den Eltern dabei helfen bei anderen
Dingen auch also
es stimmt wenn man hinfährt und so
rauskommt dann aus der Schule man hat so
einen Korridor für sich zu sein damit
Freunden zu sein der einen schon mal ein
bisschen
einstimmt oder oder wieder runterholt
das ist so und das fehlt dann wenn man
von der einen Ort ins andere kommt
komplett aber also es bleibt Möglichkeit
Selbständigkeit zu erlernen und es gibt
sicherlich auch Möglichkeit für die
Eltern in die Diskussion zu gehen in den
Streit zu gehen viele tun sich damit
schwer auch einfach weil sie vielleicht
müde sind oder weil sie erschöpft sind
und viele tun sich einfach auch so damit
schwer dass sie auch in der Politik da
hat man sich nämlich jetzt schwer getan
in den Streit in die Diskussion zu gehen
gestern der flüchtlingsgipfel und du
sagst letztendlich hat der überhaupt gar
keine Probleme gelöst woran fehlt es wie
es jetzt die Situation und wie muss es
Deiner Ansicht nach weitergeben sind wir
drin in deinem Thema ja der
flüchtlingsgipfel im Kanzleramt ist ein
vollkommener Reinfall gewesen hat sich
da auf minimal sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
wild kämpft für Sie